call of duty's mid-season 3 update is
bringing us some 80s action stars some
new game modes and some limited time
changes coming to warzone if you're
excited for all these changes and what's
in store chat with me in the comments
and if you enjoy the video be sure to
leave a like
all right here is everything we know
beginning with the new operators the
john rambo bundle
and the john mcclane bundle are both
coming to cold war and war zone
the john rambo bundle includes the
operator with two finishing moves
special blueprints for the ak-47
m60 and combat knife you'll also get an
epic watch
calling card emblem and charm the die
hard john mcclane bundle will come with
blueprints for the pharah 83
the mp5 and one undisclosed tactical
rifle
which they didn't reveal in the blog
post or the trailer but my guess is the
og
no one kills him with me this half of
the season we will be seeing the
baseball bat melee weapon
and the amp 63 which is now classified
as a pistol
and can be dual-wielded you can't keep
getting away with this
[Music]
let's talk about warzone season 3 is
going to bring some limited time changes
to war zone
beginning with the nakatomi plaza
straight from die hard 1.
here you'll be able to pursue mission
objectives including disarming c4 on the
building's roof
and interrupting arms deals gone wrong a
larger objective involving the nakatomi
vault will also be available
using special key cards you and your
team can crack the vault and claim all
of the glorious loot
[Music]
another point of interest is the new
survival camps from rambo first blood
part 2.
10 of these camps are scattered across
for dansk and contain loot as well as
dog tags of fallen soldiers the blog
post indicated that finding enough of
these leads to some sort of reward
which leads us to our next point of
interest the cia outpost
this outpost is converted from one of
the airplane hangars to the north
and it looks just like the one in the
movie you know this one
here you'll be able to deliver those dog
tags in exchange for some air support
[Music]
also coming to warzone are some limited
time game modes
the first is power grab a smaller battle
royale with 100 players
no gulag and only five collapsing
circles
so since there's no gulag you're only
able to buy your teammates back
or acquire dog tags kill confirm style
and the last few changes coming to war
zone are the combat bow kill streak and
the ballistic knife
moving on to cold war we're finally
going to see the standoff map return
from black ops 2
as well as the dugo map for multi-team
modes some new game modes are coming to
cold war too
including die hard point this mode is
like hardpoint meets cranked
teams will battle it out to reach a
score of 200 before the time runs out
if your crank timer runs out you explode
so you want to stay on those objectives
and get those kills
doing so also gets you perks like faster
sliding speed
faster ads and a larger radius for when
you actually do blow up
and then you blow up last but certainly
not least we're going to see some
updates and changes for zombies mode
to start tons of weapons are getting
buffs including the zrg 20 millimeter
the far 83 the lc10 and more custom
blueprints can now also be applied to
your zombies loadout
we'll also be getting a new outbreak
quest unlike past outbreak missions
this one will sort of tie into more of
the zombies story
the blog post says this outbreak quest
will set the stage for the next round
based zombies map that treyarch is
currently working on
so while we're still waiting for the
next actual zombies map don't worry
this outbreak quest will have its own
easter eggs to hunt for
but like last time we'll have to wait
for treyarch to announce when the hunt
can begin
cranked is also coming to firebase z and
d machina
in this new mode called crank 2 no time
to crank
kills will keep you alive a new order
event is also coming to outbreak
this looks like another one of those
optional missions you'll find on your
map
so if you engage these orders i'm sure
you'll be rewarded the same way you
would by
feeding the dragon or avenging the other
requiem soldiers
and lastly we're getting a new samantha
max's operator bundle
this one is called the death's veil
maxis it features this cool new skin
where she's rocking the veil on the face
cover
and it'll also come with blueprints for
the amp63
and one of the lmgs they didn't say
which one oh before i forget call of
duty mobile is also getting some of
these updates
including the john rambo and john
mcclane bundles
as well as the new mode called guns
blazing in this mode if you get enough
kills
you dual wield death machines and get
increased health
sounds pretty crazy let me know down in
the comments which updates you're
excited for
war zone cold war the new weapons the
new modes chat with me down in the
comments
drop a like if you enjoyed the video and
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you